hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream uh we have a really exciting
conversation today with secretary arne
duncan uh
secretary of education under barack
obama uh but before we get into that i
will give my standard of
uh announcements uh first of all just a
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit it can only exist through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate and making a donation i also want
to give a special thanks to several
organizations that have stepped up
during the covid crisis we were already
running a bit a bit of a deficit
pre-covid and then you could imagine
when covet hit our traffic went through
the roof we've been trying to accelerate
programs for students teachers and
parents and so our our deficit only grew
and so special thanks to bank for
america google.org att fasting of
artists and the many other supporters
big and small across the board those
dollars make a huge difference in our
ability to
serve really the country and really the
planet
keep learning through this really really
tough period
also want to remind everyone about the
homeroom with sal the podcast which is
as i said before it's a way to consume
this this live stream in a way that is
safe while you are driving
although you can also consume it when
you are not driving so anywhere you get
your podcast look up homeroom with sal
it's a slightly modified version of
these live streams so with that i'm
excited to introduce someone uh who is
an expert on all things education uh
someone who i look up to and uh consider
to be a good friend uh secretary arne
duncan former secretary of education
under the obama administration and
managing partner of chicago cred arne
thanks for joining us
i'm thrilled to be here and so i just
got to say just as a as a parent as a
dad you've been so helpful to my two
kids as they were growing up and just
really really appreciate everything
you're doing for millions of kids not
just across the country but across the
planet and whatever i can do to be
helpful to you um i just want to be a
good a good teammate to your
extraordinary work so thank you
no thank you actually you know obviously
we've interacted many times over the
last few years but i just had a
flashback to the first time we met which
was on video conference you were
secretary of education khan academy was
like only a year you know we were on top
of a a tea shop and i had a video
conference with the secretary of
education so i put on a jacket i put on
a tie uh but by the end of the
conversation i felt so comfortable with
you that i said and then you know they
had stopped recording i said arnie can i
tell you a secret and you said what and
i stood up and i was wearing shorts and
so that was all very prescient
for the for the coven world
you've always been ahead of your time
boy
i'm i've always been ahead of the time i
mean now even shorts i consider formal
but anyway we don't have to
go so so
sorry i mean maybe a good place to start
i mean where
obviously you know there's three
multiple layers of crises going on
there's a healthcare crisis there's an
education there's a economic crisis and
there's an education crisis and i think
those really are where everyone's minds
are
you know you've been secretary of
education
if this pandemic were happening in
2012 uh or actually you know even
earlier in
what do you see as a role for the
federal government how what do you think
needs to happen to make sure that people
keep learning
well let me just add to those
unfortunately that long list of crises
you talked about i would just add a you
know a health crisis a public health
crisis of systemic racism that we are
still trying to reckon with and you know
all the inequities that we know exists
across across every part of our society
um education is is not exempt from that
and systemic racism is part and parcel
of our educational system and happy to
talk about this so the challenges are
many
and let me be very clear we made you
know more than our share of mistakes
happy to talk about successes happy to
talk about failures but i can tell you
sal from the bottom of my heart as we
came to work every single day trying to
do what was right for children and i
would say education is the ultimate
bipartisan issue nonpartisan issue
there's nothing political about more
kids having access to pre-k and raising
high school graduation rates and having
more young people you know go on to
college once they graduate and
attracting and retaining great great
teachers and you know doing more
technology as you've done so so well so
for me this has never ever been about
politics it's about policy what i
promised you we would have done is me
and my counterpart at health and human
services are kathleen sebelius who was
the former governor of kansas would have
been locked at the hip um tom frieden
who ran the cdc he was a remarkable you
know uh leader in the medical space we
would have been locked at the hip
we would have been very very transparent
and open and honest
as you know information we're learning
more things you know every week every
day we still are you have to constantly
be communicating with tremendous
transparency and urgency but also
humility to the american public
i promise you we would have taken this
extraordinarily seriously i promise you
we wouldn't have buried it like the
current administration i promise you we
wouldn't have called it a hoax i promise
you we wouldn't have put a stigma behind
wearing masks
um and it's just interesting
you know my focus has always been on
educating kids and giving them a chance
in life and trying to break cycles of
poverty through education but this has
brought another lens our our first
priority our first responsibility is to
keep children and parents and teachers
alive and safe and healthy
and so that's the framework through
which we would have taken on this work
um every day and i will say i you know
again i just it's just my i'm always
honest
wha what
what is you know if you well
if you were whatever the next
administration is if if you found
yourself or you're advising the next
secretary of education what levers are
there at the federal level to help us as
we go through what's hopefully a short
few months of continuing kind of this
covid strangeness and then what needs to
happen after kovid to make sure that the
damage isn't long lasting and what can
you do at the federal level that's
what's always really interesting what
can the secretary of education really do
here
well there's so much that
that the next administration has to do
and let me just give you you know a
couple different things to think about
um i will always start with pre-k
that we have to get our babies off to a
good start for me that's the best
investment we can make we got to stop
the the the producer saying if you can
tilt your camera a little bit sorry i
don't want to
tilt it down a little bit you're getting
cut off by your name there you go
perfect okay sorry i didn't want to
is that is that okay much much much
better yes sorry
i gotta work on the technical side of
this stuff so people are sitting behind
the scenes today
i'd start with a massive investment in
pre-k and getting more and more children
across the country ready for school
secondly we have to close the digital
divide
next administration could do that with
the fcc we got to make access to devices
to wi-fi to the internet as ubiquitous
as as electricity and drinking water
kids have to be able to learn anything
they want anytime anywhere inner-city
communities rural communities suburban
communities native american reservations
that has to be the norm
we have to think very differently as you
and i have talked about about the school
day the school year the calendar
having summer off for everybody doesn't
make sense we have a lot of kids that
need to catch up you know lengthening
the time which kids have a chance to
learn is so important i think we have to
think differently about the length of
time we ask kids to go to school we've
had a kindergarten through 12th grade
model this worked well for the last
hundred years i don't think it's suited
well at all for the next five or ten
years let alone the next 20 or 30. i
think we have to move to a pre-k through
14 model and make that the norm and then
finally for those kids that have been
most impacted by the covet slide and
then summerslide and then you know may
not be back in school this fall and that
could literally be a couple million kids
south so these are not small numbers i
would love to see a national tutoring
initiative
where we can work with those children
physically virtually to try and help
them catch up um we can't allow them to
have a last year because we lose a year
we may lose them forever and so there's
so much that the nexus administration
has to do work with tremendous urgency
invest i would say a great you know a
great military is our best defense but a
great educational system is our best
offense as a country we need an
administration that truly understands
that we have to invest in kids and
ultimately in our families and our
communities in our country
and i couldn't agree more with pretty
much everything you just said i mean
just taking them one by one you know the
digital divide that's one you and i have
talked a lot about obviously even to
start accessing khan academy and other
resources or just participating in
digital learning or distance learning
you need it
what's your sense of what it would take
to get you know make it so like no
family in the country does not have
sufficient internet access just like
clean drinking water heating like you
mentioned you know my back of the
envelope calculations it's a it's one
percent of the trillion that we're
throwing around to stimulus right now
and it seems like everyone's behind it
so what would what takes us across the
finish line
yeah what what always i guess get both
gives me hope but frankly infuriates me
is sal this is not like a cure for
cancer this is not putting a man on mars
this is simply a lack of vision a lack
of political will a lack of courage and
frankly a lack of caring about our
nation's kids so the the amount of money
would be you know a couple billion
dollars you know whatever we'll figure
out what that number is um it is not
overwhelming um you have the the fcc an
e-rate that has access to billions of
dollars that could be used in a
different way and so the funding issue
here to your point is basically a
rounding error it's just believing in
kids and understanding we need to help
every child wherever they are find their
genius you know find what they love to
do you know find what they want to do
with their lives and i say all the time
that you know talent is is evenly
distributed in our country opportunity
is not we got to close the opportunity
gap we got to make sure opportunity
meets that talent wherever and
everywhere that it is
digital divide that seems like a
no-brainer from a from a federal
department of education point of view
it's a small percentage of the
multi-trillions of stimulus that we're
putting out there these other things
that you talked about like the school
day this calendar uh allowing for a
competency-based learning i don't think
you said it but i've heard you other
times say things like that uh or a
tutoring program
is can that happen at the federal level
or is that something that kind of the
federal can influence the states to do
yeah both of those all of the above so
let's sort of take it one at a time so
for me the the e-rate you know the
e-rate program that's a federal program
that's at the national level and again
this is a national crisis this is it has
to be a national initiative so you do
you do that closing the digital divide
we can't leave that you know local
locality by locality community by
community state by state we do that for
every kid now you know why are we
waiting what are we waiting for so that
leadership has to happen there i think
it's something like a national tutoring
program and what you're get what you're
getting going in terms of volunteer
initiative is extraordinarily important
i just want to help you do that and see
that scale that leadership can come at
the federal level more resources for
pre-k um that can come at the federal
level we invested during the obama
administration more than a billion
dollars in pre-k is one of the things i
was most proud of we just need to do
more of that and work with congress to
do that some of the stuff as you said is
very very local thinking differently
about the calendar the school day
the school week
summers thinking about a pre-k through
14 you know model for education in
america rather than k-12 um those are
things that absolutely would need to
happen at the local level what the
federal government could do is they
could provide resources to help people
think about those things help them model
it you know try and scale it learn what
works what doesn't you have an amazing
opportunity always to convene at the
federal level um to put resources by
behind innovation and creativity and so
again whether it's hard dollars and some
of the stuff or just leadership and
vision
at the federal level that you can play
an extraordinarily important point uh
part in helping give kids a chance in
life
no that makes a lot of sense and we're i
mean told by our technical team arne if
you just touch your screen every now and
then it might be because your ipad is
going into screen saver mode so just you
know give it a little love every every
few minutes and it'll be it'll be good
so we're getting a ton of questions uh
you know there's a question from scott
yang saying yo sal
when can things return to normal and
i'll extend it because i think you know
scott is referring to normal in the
school system broadly and obviously you
referred to this you know the notion of
teachers aren't feeling safe fully
protected we clearly don't have a
vaccine out there
what are you hearing as
you know the best practices that school
districts are doing to navigate these
times some people are fully open some
people aren't some people are kind of
hybrid what would you advise the school
district right now to get up and running
couple thoughts first of all school
districts schools they're not islands
they're not bubbles they exist in
community and so the best thing if we
truly care about kids the best thing we
can do is to beat down this virus in our
communities
and we have not done a good job with
that we've lacked discipline
we've opened bars before we opened
schools which didn't make any sense i
think the way we have to think about
this is going to be public health first
public education second
and then reopening the economy third
it's got to be in that order public
health public education or reopen the
economy we've done that all backwards
with disastrous results so that's the
most important thing we can do the
second thing i'll say
is that uh
i think school districts in the absence
of federal leadership have shown just
unbelievable you know creativity in
doing this so how you open carefully how
you open slowly how you open with the
most vulnerable children first or the
youngest children's first we're seeing
fantastic examples around the country as
you notice now we haven't seen big
outbreaks where districts are opening up
they're doing it carefully they're doing
it thoughtfully um kids are really
adhering to you know to wearing masks
and social distancing um we're seeing
frankly less of that at the college
level in higher education
and so schools i think are leading the
way in terms of how we get there the
final point i'll make and this is a
really important one to me
i don't want to go back to quote unquote
normal because normal didn't serve
millions of children well enough
we have to that's not that's not a high
enough bar
we have to use this time to reimagine
reinvent education do it through a lens
of of equity of equity what's fair
what's just how do we close these
opportunity gaps how do we give every
child a chance to be successful and we
have to use this very very dark time to
try and leapfrog to something to be much
better for our you know 53 54 million
children across the country who are
going to school
yeah that makes sense what's your sense
you know when we talk to a lot of
districts even the ones that have been
able to to mostly close the digital
divide they're also talking i have a
school teacher who shares the cul-de-sac
in our neighborhood she teaches fifth
grade and this is in a middle income
upper middle income neighborhood she's
telling me that in her class of 30
there's two or three kids that are just
disengaged and she thinks they have
internet access but maybe they're there
they don't have the supports at home and
what we're hearing in large urban school
districts is the problem's much much
worse even when there is internet access
how do we reach those kids or what do
they need what kind of support can we
give them
yeah that's so important and let me say
first that we have so many in in you
know in school systems and individual
schools you have so many different
responsibilities and it's not just the
education part now i will come back and
answer that the first thing that schools
do across the country is they serve tens
of millions of kids
two sometimes three meals a day and
throughout the pandemic starting in
early march
we've done a weekly call with school
districts across the country who through
all of this as physical buildings shut
down those schools continue to be food
distribution centers and drive-throughs
in front of it just amazing leadership
and hard work to make that happen um
secondly we have to take care of kids
social and emotional health and so
telehealth teachers counselors you know
psychologists social workers reaching
out to children um many of whom are
dealing with a lot of trauma before this
many of whom are dealing with
unfortunately a lot more trauma now due
to pandemic due to economic insecurity
due to systemic racism due to food
insecurity we have to take care of those
those kids and then we get to the
education part so as we talk about you
know so much you know high tech and
internet and broad broadband all that's
great but to answer your question
directly the most important thing i
think we can do now to reach those kids
who may have disappeared who are
struggling we have to do we have to go
old school we have to go visit them at
their homes and it's been fascinating
with the young man i work with here in
chicago trying to reduce violence on the
south and west sides uh the past few
months i've spent more time that i ever
have on port steps and just sitting and
talking to guys you know
at their house on their block in their
neighborhood i have to say it's been
it's been an amazing learning experience
and just not sitting behind a desk you
know not having them come to our offices
although we're glad to slowly be opening
our physical offices but just meeting
them where they are and listening and
getting a sense of what's going on
has been invaluable and building our
trust and building our relationships and
so there's no substitute for again
teachers whoever is you know again maybe
not in the in the playbook in the
traditional playbook but this is not
very non-traditional time
i would just strongly urge not just
teachers but educational leaders to go
find those kids go to their homes talk
to them talk to their parents find out
what's going on find out what we can do
to help them re-engage and i always say
when kids are struggling when they're
you know when they're not able to
participate in school when their
behavior isn't you know isn't great um
for me that's always a symptom of a
problem and the problem is much deeper
and we got to not deal with the symptoms
here we got to deal with the root causes
whatever they may be
no it makes it makes a ton of sense and
you alluded to it i mean tell us a
little bit about
the work that you're doing now at cred
uh
what what is that work why have you kind
of put your you know you could be doing
anything in education or beyond why are
you focusing your energies there
yeah so i'm
obsessed just laser-like focused on
reducing gun violence in chicago and
i would tell you so i started to lose
friends to gun violence when i was a
teen i'm 55 and how so that's 40 years
ago
honestly i think that
hap when that happens it it shapes you
and probably scars you in some ways a
little bit difficult to talk about um
during my time leaving the chicago
public schools there's a whole bunch i
was really really proud of we can talk
about that all day but on my watch
during my seven and a half years leading
chicago public schools on average we had
one of our children one of our students
killed every two weeks due to gun
violence it was a staggering rate of
loss
and thank goodness it was never in
school but it was you know and it's
going home on the bus walking to the
corner store
shot through a living room window you
know 7 30 in the morning you know
getting ready for school and i just feel
i don't feel we i know we as adults fail
to keep our kids safe
and when our family moved to dc
in 2009 very naively
in hindsight i thought we were rock
bottom i thought we couldn't get any
worse in terms of violence and for a
whole host of things a whole host of
reasons things got a lot worse in seven
years we were in dc
so coming back home
chicago has given me every opportunity
you know educationally academically
athletically socially culturally i owe
this city everything for me to come back
here and not deal with this crisis
didn't feel right so we're just working
directly with the young men on the south
and west sides most likely to shoot and
be shot and helping them move out of
that life
and start to be the real strong
community leaders they need to be
to take our city to a much much safer
place
the level of fear and trauma that our
children are growing up with
on the south and west sides is
unimaginable and it's not right it's not
fair it's not their fault and we're
trying to break those cycles
what do you think is the major lever i
mean you talked about just that
door-to-door work making connections
with young people
is that really the core work or are
there other levers
yeah this work is very very complicated
so i don't want to ever oversimplify so
i'll just say they're five what we call
five pillars to our work so one is
street outreach we have guys who you
know formerly were in the you know in
the gangs in the cliques who have what
we call lto licensed to operate who they
work to mediate conflicts actually it's
crazy this past weekend saturday night
one of our our street outreach workers
actually uh successfully negotiated a
hostage situation the police stood down
and let him handle it because he had to
let the relationship was unbelievable
there so in street outreach that
basically is our hr function they bring
young men um into our program once guys
come to us we do we do four other things
um every guy has a life coach we always
say experience can be the best teacher
but it doesn't have to be your
experience our life coaches have lived
often very tough lives but have come out
the back end and want to give back and
want to help out
they're remarkable we have a clinical
team the amount of trauma our guys are
dealing with is extraordinary we see all
the time that hurt people hurt people we
have to help guys heal and deal with a
lifetime of trauma we have an education
team we've had well over 100 guys get
high school diplomas we have a set of
folks actually in college now and it's
been fantastic to see that happen and
then we have a jobs team and ultimately
our our goal is to move guys out of the
street economy into the legal economy
and we have jobs teams that helps in
that transition um guys work with us for
you know nine months a year 15 months
then we have about uh four dozen
employers who hire at the back end and
so those are the five pillars uh that uh
that give us a chance to give guys a
chance in life and i always say after
you were giving them not a second chance
but a first chance
no that's incredibly powerful incredibly
important work um
one question here i know we're running
low on time from facebook carl james
markhart it's about higher education
with the cost of university education in
the states at a record high and with
covet 19 demonstrating the extent to
which university education is
self-taught when online resources are
readily available how can the next
government improve access to cost
effective tertiary education
which lead to accredited qualifications
which are valued by employers
big questions yes i think i think this
you know this pandemic is forcing us to
to be creative and think very
differently about education so what can
be delivered not just what what can be
delivered online maybe what's even
better delivered more effectively more
efficiently delivered online um we're
gonna have we're coming out of this much
smarter than we went into this
where how we utilize our best teachers
whether it's k-12 our best professors
on the higher education side again what
you've done and what you did for our you
know my kids is you're an amazing
teacher you didn't teach 25 kids in one
class or you know 120 you know freshman
or sophomores um you've touched tens of
millions of kids and how do we you'll
create systems where our best
instructors and whatever it is um have
more range have more access uh to young
people again whether it's k-12 or on the
higher on the higher ed side
i think as i said earlier as a country
we have to move to a pre-k to 14 model
not everyone has to go to a four-year
university but i want to make sure they
have the opportunity to do that and so
we have to make sure every young person
coming out of high school
get four year university two year
community college trade technical
vocational training that they have a
plan beyond that
i think we will see
more low cost high quality models coming
out of higher education
again the federal government could do a
lot more to incentivize that and put
some resources behind that and then the
final thing i would love to see the
federal government do is where we're
seeing universities the goal for me is
not to just enroll young people is to
have them graduate is to get that
diploma the worst thing you can have is
all that college debt and no degree
that's the worst position but if you
graduate you can be you're going to be
in pretty good shape and so i think
again the uh at the federal level we can
incentivize those universities or those
new models where whether it's you know
uh english language learners whether
it's pell recipients whether it's first
generation college goers or all the
above who's doing the best job not just
again of attracting them of enrolling
them but of helping them graduate
i'd like to put a lot more resources
behind those traditional institutions or
new creative institutions that are that
are emerging and frankly less resources
behind those places that aren't as
serious about helping people get that
piece of paper that's so critically
important
no it's all about transparency not only
are they graduating but what are their
job placement et cetera so this next
question there's been a lot of
conversation on social
social media about your the your
background uh this is a very serious
question from facebook ruth branigan
asks where is arnie was it his turn to
bowl
i think that is in revelation
bowl i think they think what behind you
are bowling
[Laughter]
shoes looks like a nice bowling alley
with a nice view you don't want to see
me bowl so i i will tell you the uh that
the folks who's uh are kind enough to
give our non-profit office space here
it's actually an interesting story they
um they bronze the shoes of the mentors
of all the people who work at their
company and basically said we built this
company upon your shoulders so they
bronzed the actual shoes of the mentors
of all of their
their their their lead their their
employees here so that the company gives
me spaces vista and um yeah it's a
pretty remarkable story and people come
visit people often go show them the shoe
of their mentor the person who had the
biggest influence on their life
i love that idea well you know in the
remaining time we have left just in one
question there's a lot of people of all
ages we have parents watching we have
teachers watching we have young people
watching
we're going through hard times
you know what advice do you have for
them in navigating their education or
beyond yeah well say a couple things
first i just want to say thank you to
everybody thank you to teachers thank
you to parents thank you to students i
hate that it's such a hard time now
i hate that there's just a desperate
lack of leadership and seriousness a
purpose at the federal level and
dishonesty there but what i see from
real people in real communities every
single day is extraordinary and so just
from the bottom of my heart thank you
for everyone who is working so hard and
extraordinarily stressful and difficult
times on behalf of our kids
um secondly i always want to say you
know we need to take care of ourselves
but more importantly we have to take
care of each other now this is a time of
extraordinary stress i actually don't
love the term self-care because it sort
of puts all the onus on the individual
just to take care of themselves um i
think this has got to be we as a
community have to come together look out
for each other you know take care of
each other check on people ask very
honestly and listen to you know how are
you doing how are you feeling i'll speak
to myself i have some great days and
i've had some really really difficult
days and we have to take that that part
of this you know very very seriously um
third just to sort of be kind to
ourselves take a little pressure off you
know don't don't don't push you know
don't push so hard
don't be so hard on ourselves and we're
all trying to do more um i've probably
never felt more inadequate um there's so
much i'm trying to do every single day
as you are and so many are because the
need is so great um but at the same time
we just have to sort of be you know be
kind to ourselves and the final thing
i'll say is that you know in a really
dark and difficult time i'm actually
tremendously hopeful
and
the sense of our common humanity the
sense of our interconnectedness
um how much we have to show empathy um
everybody's seeing that you know if my
kids are okay but my neighbor's kids
aren't okay um that's not good enough if
our family is okay but the family down
the block or in another neighborhood
they're not okay that's got that you
know that's not good enough
i think we are really realizing in an
unbelievably concrete way um how much we
need each other how interdependent we
are um how much we have in common and if
we can continue to to never not forget
that continue to sort of have that um in
our hearts and minds and more
importantly in our children's hearts and
minds that actually makes me wildly
hopeful about where our country can go
i'm not just coming out of the pandemic
but for the next couple decades
well thank you for that as always uh
very very inspirational we're going
through hard times but but secretary
duncan arne thank you so much for
joining this was this was really
valuable
thanks for all of your leadership
well thanks everyone for for joining as
always a great conversation with
secretary duncan i want to remind
everyone for tomorrow's show we're going
to have laurie santos who teaches a very
popular course at yale university called
psychology and the good life and so this
is a course that actually tries to
tackle i think something that all of us
are trying to do which is just how do we
live our best life and you know a lot of
what uh arnie was just talking about of
self-care uh which doesn't have to be
self-driven uh which is you know how do
you nourish yourself your mental
well-being and obviously it's especially
important given everything that's going
on in the world right now so join us
tomorrow uh so and and and i guess
onward see you tomorrow
you